podcast special guest about to get her
up by the way go watch our interview
it's out right now Slimer Roni is here
representing Memphis about the rap man
let's get to it come on man yeah
hey
if I'm reaching for this rocket then I'm
out of pocket I Cross My T's and die my
eyes and knock it out of socket taking
shots of me don't work because I'm quick
to block it so when the [__] do you help
me cut like they need to stop it said I
ain't Batman I ain't saving [__] we
doing not a robin [__] coming like
they too but be sweeter the Baskin
robbers man I'm coming like Crisco I get
heated then get it pop and put the
stupid [__] I say or not hey it ain't
directed I ain't respected [__] I've
been out of dress if I out of people
talking [__] swallow you spitting the
gist man I don't be in the meats cause
he [__] should be messy I be putting
that [__] on I don't need no one to
dress it guess me up baby I'm pressure
hip on the Glock on my dresser he eat me
your phone with pleasure Big Daddy
[__] can't miss you might not I know
my haters be so full of regret but
honestly they should feel blessed we
ever met they see me 24 7 from TVs to
the net if you thought you would see me
you ain't seen nothing yet huh swimming
put see she got some ass on the [__]
wanna smash it be hard not to pass on
her I'm hitting the gas playing catch up
hit the dash on them in some vintage
drip cause the group Watch Me splash on
them I get finer and finding like wine
kill [__] without even trying not one of
those that you can play with Heaven
Street [__] crying I'm going stupid bet
the folks who daddy me feeling dumb my
time will not be lying I tell him imma
come there I believe it's Tac I got this
[__] on my lungs the Blondy feelings are
perfect between my indexing phone I tell
them had my bread ready but they tried
to feed me Crumbs went bad one
[__] sound my [__] pulling
over drunk only tiny Bishop guys for one
night talking with tight thongs only
tiny [__] dancing when they talking
that was hard thank you
hey what up y'all appreciate you guys
watching this week's freestyle we're
dropping another one next week and
sometimes we drop more than one in a
week but they're always brought to you
by LRG baby that's right loving me some
LRG always and right now if you go to
the website L Dash R Dash g.com and you
use the promo code bootleg you're gonna
get 30 off 30 off that's almost half
at checkout that's right all right shout
out to LRG one more time L Dash R Dash
g.com and when you check out use that
promo code bootleg and save 30 off the
freestyles we'll be back next week
always brought to you by LRG baby